Avengers: Infinity War is a nonstop ride of
block-rocking shockers, from the unexpected
deaths of almost everyone fans love to the
crushing finale in which the villain clearly
wins, at least, until Avengers 4 comes out.
But one of the movie's most shocking moments
comes within minutes of the start of the adventure,
and we're not just talking about Loki croaking.
We're speaking, of course, of the thorough
beatdown that the Mad Titan Thanos administers
to the Avengers' Big Green Guy, who pops out
of nowhere on the Asgardian ship to ambush
Thanos, with hopes of solving the problem
the villain presents before it even starts.
What actually happens is that the Hulk gets
beaten down and more or less given the full
"Puny God" treatment after his attack on the
purple man with the really gross chin.
As a matter of fact, Hulk gets beat up so
hard during the fight that for the first time
ever, he's actually left unwilling to fight
on Bruce Banner's behalf.
But how did the Mad Titan manage to hold his
own against the Hulk before acquiring enough
Infinity Stones to make him effectively unbeatable?
Before the movie begins, Thanos gets the purple
Power Stone from Guardians of the Galaxy by
invading Xandar.
Is that what he uses to get one over on the
Hulk?
The answer may surprise you.
It turns out, when Thanos fights the Hulk
for the first time, he's not using the Power
Stone at all.
He's just that strong on his own.
According to the movie's commentary track
with directors Joe and Anthony Russo and writers
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely, the
filmmakers behind Infinity War made a conscious
decision to leave the power-increasing Infinity
Stone out of the Thanos-Hulk fight.
For the sake of maximum intimidation, Thanos
starts off the conflict at his base strength,
a classic Dragon Ball sort of move if there
ever was one.
Joe Russo and Stephen McFeely have a little
back-and-forth on the film's commentary track
regarding Thanos' formidable baseline power
level.
McFeely raises the issue during the Asgardian
ship scene, saying,
"Here you see the early establishment of just
how fearsome Thanos is even without [the stones],
he's got one stone here, and I don't think
he's even using it."
To which Russo replies,
"He's not using it.
This is to show that Thanos, the Genghis Khan
of the universe, is unbeatable in one-on-one
battle.
He's conquered thousands of worlds.
He's a much more polished fighter than the
Hulk, and he dismantles the Hulk fairly quickly."
The screenwriters previously discussed Thanos'
awesome skill set in an interview with Collider,
saying they wanted "to announce Thanos as
the biggest villain in the MCU."
"By defeating hulk relatively savagely and easily you're hopefully."
there's a sense of dread over the course of the rest of the movie for anyone who will come up against him.
Anyone who's seen Infinity War would likely
attest to the fact that the early beatdown
Hulk takes from Thanos goes a long way toward
proving the villain's threat level.
Not only does he have the strength of the
Hulk, he also has a brilliantly ambitious
mind that runs circles around the Hulk's gray
matter.
He's strong, which makes him threatening,
but it's his brain that makes him terrifying.
But even with the filmmakers' comments taken
into consideration, the answer as to why Thanos
proves to be more than an even match for the
Hulk comes down to something simple: Because
it's extremely cool.
Make 19 movies' worth of a convincing comic
book universe on screen, and you've earned
the right to occasionally throw in something
awesomely unexpected like a Thanos who's way
stronger than anyone thought he'd be.
No one expected Space Grimace to be able to
wipe the floor with Hulk like that.
Even on rewatch, it's a heck of a way to start
a movie.